the jurogan experience
um but i was free to carry on so i
carried on about another four weeks
you know got up onto the tundra
visited some reindeer herders you know
got some very remote supplements and
spent the final
sort of 10 days hiking on on the frozen
arctic ocean you know camping out you
know under some of the most incredible
starscapes and northern lights it was
beautiful really good time
um i arrived in tixi this port town at
the end which used to have i think like
15 000 people now has about 5 000 people
it's another one of these the russians
have a phrase for this
like a dying town a town more dead than
alive
um and
on arrival in tixi
someone who i'd met on the road weeks
earlier who i got in touch with on
arrival he said you know get in touch
we'll catch up
um he told me that the fsb the kgb
wanted to talk to me and i thought right
well just take the bull by the horns
i'll just go to their building and i'll
say i hear you want to talk to me i'm
here
and they were a bit taken aback by that
and they said can you come back at this
time tomorrow so i did
and um
they said they
it felt like an interrogation but
eventually turned out it was just this
standard procedure they asked me these
questions who i was the
name of my family members the history of
my family did any of my ancestors ever
were they ever in the british forces do
i have any political beliefs was i in
the army just all these kind of
standards suspicious questions
and it went on about two three hours and
when we were finally done the guy said
okay well that's it you're you're free
to go i was like oh great he said make
sure you visit the museum there's a
mammoth skeleton you know have a good
time good luck to you
i went back to where i was staying
and um
i was recording so i took with me a
little zoom like a little dictaphone you
know a lot of people use it for podcasts
i think
and for for another podcast with a
friend that'll surface in a month or so
i've been recording my experiences in my
own voice along the way of the cold the
people i met the odd conversation with
other people
but naturally with what was going on and
people telling me of their opinions
about ukraine
in my own little recordings in my tent
at night sometimes i get a little sort
of political i guess and aft after that
um encounter with the
uh in usquiga when they came to my door
these policemen the first time sorry
four weeks back i know we're jumping
around
um when they came to my door i was
recording on my dictaphone
and i went to answer the door and just
slipped it in my pocket and they said
right come to the police station now
and so i went but it was still recording
so i had a live mic throughout this
whole police process and the first thing
they did in the police station was take
my phone turn it off so i wasn't
recording and so little did they know
there was this hot mic in my pocket
um so after that was done i got back to
where i was staying i kind of in my own
words except what had happened took the
little micro sd card out um and then
unscrewed a plug adapter you know from
like a british plug to a russian plug
unscrewed that wrapped the sd card up in
a little scrap of white paper slotted it
in there screwed it back up it's like
you know i don't want to lose this
it's not really a huge problem but best
just to hide it have it safe
up in dixie i sort of recorded my final
thoughts uh again and i had this little
sd card it was just on the table
um and another one i was worried you
know my journal that my diary that i've
been writing in each day i was worried
that that might get taken you know
because slowly
the with the villages i passed through
towards the end you know it was made
very clear that the authorities were
waiting for me in dixie i thought well
you know that might get seized
not the end of the world if it does if i
with my gopro take a picture of every
single page and i can hide that little
sd card in the same plug socket
but when the knock came on my door in
dixie i'd been asleep i'd actually
fallen asleep reading kafka
the trial this guy getting arrested and
not knowing what it's all about
they came to the door and everything was
just kind of out and they said um it was
the police again they said can you come
to the station for registration
and i said again well this is you know a
little ominous but registration fine i'd
already you know the day before spoken
to the fsb i knew everything was fine
and in the station um
it quickly became clear well after about
an hour of just this long asking lots of
questions i said well can i go now and
they said no no you can't go and that's
when i understood i'm under arrest and
this is maybe a little bit more serious
and once again
they well they said who have you spoken
to who have you met in dixie
and i said um well i met this guy
who i'd met on the road who
it's a small town so i didn't want to
lie to them i thought best just to say
who i'd met so i met this guy and i've
met this other bloke
and they didn't know who either of these
people were and they were asking
questions about who they were and
without leaving the room without making
a call without doing any texting me
having just explained to them who these
people were and they didn't know who
they were they quickly said right well
both those people are um are providing
witness to say that you have been
conducting journalism and asking
questions about ukraine so you know they
sort of essentially got me to provide
them with false witnesses
um and
this process went on for hours they got
an english teacher to translate for us
and
as the hours passed the english teacher
became more and more fed up she was
meant to be i think someone with a
disease
in the town there was a bake sale to
raise money for him and she was meant to
be cooking cakes cupcakes with her
daughter that evening and you know i'd
ruined this because it was already
they took me at about 4 30.
anyway at 9 30 after a lot of waiting
around they finally said right you're
going to court now i thought well it's 9
30. how's that going to work and they
took me to another building an old
soviet looking apartment blocks that
building but on the third floor there
was a courtroom and
in the courtroom they got this judge
who just seemed pissed off you know he
had been dragged out of his home at 9 30
at night to deal with some thing
and
the teacher was so pissed off by this
point that she wasn't really translating
in full anymore so you know the judge
would speak a whole you know paragraph
and she would give me a half sentence in
in translation
and so the trial unfolded
i had been supposedly
you know conducting journalism again
they had these witnesses who said i said
this that and the other
and they also said most worryingly that
i've been photographing
restricted military sites or sensitive
military sites
and the judge found me guilty and he
said uh you'll pay a fine again not much
like 70 bucks something like that um and
you are banned from russia for five
years and you have to leave you'll be
deported
and i thought right you know yeah it's
not the end of the world you know it
looks like russia's not particularly a
place to go back to for five years you
know it's fine and so at that point as
far as i was aware i would be i would
fly back to yakutsk
get my own flight back to england via
some other third country and then fly
home done
um and i was taken back to my uh the
sort of apartment i'd rented in this
town
and um
probably 20 minutes later there was a
knock at the door
and it was the police again they said oh
actually you have to be in the cell
tonight pack everything you have up and
and we're going now and so with them in
front of me i had to pack everything up
among the stuff that was all kind of
laid out was one of these little sd
cards with the second half of all the
recordings from this
zoom on it
and all i could do was i had a head
torch next to it on the table because
they were watching me pack
you know head torches have that little
sort of hinge so it can sort of angle
down on your forehead
i bent the hinge down put the sd card in
that bit and just snapped it shut and
put a rubber band around the whole thing
but that just felt really precarious you
know that's not well hidden
and that's the last time i was you know
just before that point was the last time
i was unattended with all my stuff for
weeks to come as it turned out
i packed everything up we were taken to
the cell um you know fingerprinting i
was eventually about 1 30 put into this
little cell
um and you know i was thankfully tired
enough i got some sleep woke up in the
morning
and from that point onwards i was
accompanied or escorted by
bailiffs technically although they said
we're we're russia's u.s marshals
they're quite keen to sort of compare
themselves to u.s marshals
um and i had already changed my flight
that i had booked a week away to the
following day to get me back to the
capitol
and so i was deported on well
sent down to yakutsk on the flight that
i'd booked but with a man as an escort
and at this point i still thought like
i'm just i'm free when i get to yakutsk
i'll go home
on arrival in jackets there was another
bailiff waiting for me and he said right
well you have to now go and stay in this
this kind of hotel for foreigners until
you fly home and i thought well that's
not it's not ideal but again it's not
the end of the world and then on the
drive in this minibus to the detention
center it turned out yeah it was it was
a detention center for foreigners and it
was just a prison
um and you know my shoelaces were taken
away my belt was taken off all my goods
were locked up in a locker
and
you know after being processed and
checked in the door slammed or the cell
door slams shut behind me
uh and then there i am and i don't know
how long for you know that that's
you know one of the sort of bleakest
moments where i just i didn't know
what exactly is going to happen after
that
i still i suppose i was thinking a few
days and i'll probably be out
um and they were sort of saying maybe 10
days you got to wait for the paperwork
to come down from the coast or whatever
but after a few days you know time had
come and gone i was in the cell i mean
you're in the cell around the clock 24
hours a day uh not allowed outside
food's handed through a little hatch in
the cell i shared it with uh two other
men
um and after a few days they said right
you know you should be getting a lawyer
and i was allowed
on mondays wednesdays and fridays 15
minutes of access to my phone so
back home via these frantic hurried
phone calls my uh my uncle and my
girlfriend were kind of you know
arranging trying to help out um
and so we arranged for a lawyer to come
in and he said right well we'll appeal
the decision
but that appeal wasn't hurt for two
weeks
and that appeal was dismissed out of
hand i was taken to the court
and this is after two weeks you know by
this point i was you know not a happy
guy
um i mean it was almost comical going to
the court for the appeal i was so
desperate to get outside i hadn't been
outdoors for two weeks
and they said right you're going to the
court and i knew that meant i'd get to
be outdoors for a few minutes you know
as i walked from the door into the
minibus and in from the minibus into the
court at the other end
but they they put me in cuffs
and then they with another pair of
handcuffs cuffed me to one of the guards
who had a taser and there was another
guard on the other side with the taser
and
they wouldn't let me have my shoelaces
or my belt back
and i'd lost quite a lot of weight
during this trek so my trousers were
falling down my hiking shoes had these
massive you know tongues lolling out the
front and walking walking down the
courthouse corridors i was doing this
kind of
weird you know john wayne wide-need
shuffle to try and stop my trousers from
falling down meanwhile my hands are
pinned to this guy to my right
but the the judge looked at the papers
for you know like two minutes and said
yeah no it's your crimes are too serious
um
there's a political element and you know
you're you're going back into the
detention center
and
this was probably the time when i felt
most low um
about
a week earlier i had suddenly
unexpectedly been dragged onto in front
of a tv camera and interviewed and that
was a bit concerning that felt like um
you know being tried by the court of
public opinion
they had um eventually the news bit
aired i think the day before my appeal
but they had gone up to tixie and they
got witness statements one from one
bloke who i never even met saying yeah
you know he was talking about ukraine
and he's photographing these military
sites again no photos were ever provided
that you know backed up that story
and all the while
you know those those first two weeks
all of my belongings are in their
possession and the police have come and
searched they made me turn on the phone
my phone unlock it for them i had a gps
device which really freaks them out my
gopros to them look like a spy camera
but when they first laid out all my
belongings or some policeman you know i
was taking cuffed out my cell to be you
know to turn everything on for him and
sort of
on the table laid out in this neat
little row was all my items and among
them was this plug socket
and that head torch with the hidden
little um sd card in it
and although
technically those things weren't really
incriminating the fact that they're
being hidden didn't look good
and i probably should have said earlier
back in march
two months earlier they had introduced a
new law with a maximum sentence of up to
15 years for journalists
providing
or sort of spreading fake news about the
military i.e anyone really speaking the
truth about the military after the
invasion after the invasion uh and you
know these recordings had lots of me
talking about the invasion the
atrocities in butcher and all sorts and
my whole diary which up to this point
i'd kept hidden because when i was
checked into the cell while they were
going through all my stuff i just
slipped it in my trousers
because i thought this diary doesn't
look good i slipped so my trousers which
again freaked me out a little bit are
they going to frisk me are they not i
got it into the cell and then i just hit
it in plain sight among my belongings
and it was all the stuff in the locker
that the police went and looked through
so there's just a lot of things going on
i'm constantly on edge that i'm just
about to become
you know a political bargaining chip did
they find the
sd cards
no thankfully um this is actually the
first time i've spoken about those sd
cards
and you know those would have qualified
me for at least you know euro
journalists
if not espionage and the guards in the
prison who were i mean i think they were
probably nice normal guys but they
treated they were wankers to us um
i mean they kept on saying to me are you
a spy and don't fight my country you
know they would also on their phones
look up phrases in english and then kind
of chant them back at me you are a spy
walker
um and so it was it was a it's a scary
time um and after the appeal was
rejected
i then thought well you know this could
be this could be a really long time you
know i could be here for months
and the longer i'm here the more chance
there is that either they'll find some
of these these sd cards or my diary or
that they will you know some ambitious
you know cop some ambitious policeman or
bureaucrat will decide to pick up my
case again to retry try me under the
criminal offense i mean given they'd
made up most of their evidence anyway
it's no stretch to think that they could
pin on me the fake news journalist thing
and put me away for 15 years
i mean i i didn't know that i i didn't
even know of her at the time but since
getting out i've learned about and i'm
going to get her name wrong but britney
grinner yeah the basketball player who i
mean we don't really even know where she
is i think i think a bit of news came
out about her the other day but i mean
she's clearly being in my opinion i mean
it's totally outrageous but she i think
is being held you know as a prisoner
swap fodder you know they they will use
her when convenient